No I don't want to play.
Fuck.
What do I do? (Thumping in the distance )
HA WHOA RRHEY INDHHA- (Screams cut off Mark)
Hello, everybody. My name is Markiplier and welcome to night horrors.
Now this is an Indie horror game that I don't know a lot about
but I believe it might be in the same vein as a free
roam five nights at Freddy's type deal.
Oooh Hello
Well this looks moderately good.
Z to end-
Hi, I remember people calling me at night. IT NEVER ENDED WELL.
Hello- Ah, hello, hi.
Character: Hello
Phone voice: Hi, there, welcome to your new job at Fazbear Museum.
(Uncomfortable laughter from Mark) Okay.
Phone voice: Here, we are dedicated to showing off the amazing work
Of Freddy Fazbear's Pizzeria
Mark: Of course we are.
Phone voice: After the restaurant closed down
Mark: Mhmh
We tried to salvage as much of the animatronics we could.
Unfortunately the main animatronics were promised to to other companies
So... Fazbear Entertainment decided to give us two other characters
They had never been used by the restaurant
They didn't have names, but we decided to name them James Fazbear and Scrappy.
Mark: OH GOOD. What playful names.
James seems to be a concept model of Freddy
And Scrappy shows a slight resemblance to Bonnie
Since they have never been seen they're worth a fortune.
Mark: MMMMM
That's why you're here
Mark: Okay
To protect the models from getting harmed or stolen.
Mark: Uh huh.
I'm sure you may be a little worried about the models roaming
But it has never happened here like it has in the pizzeria.
The museum is currently still in construction
So we do not have much to show
But we are still working on getting some more memorabilia from the owner.
We have provided you with strong weaponry
Because we always keep the entrance door locked with a time locking mechanism
so you will need it if someone breaks in
(Mark wonders why that's a thing)
Mark: Okay..
Your office is your safe place. So make sure if you do get attacked by an intruder to keep yourself safe in there
Try not to stay in the office too long with your doors closed as door seems to start malfunctioning
if kept closed.
(Creepy laughing in the background)
That's all there is to it so, good luck and we will see you again tomorrow.
Mark: I HAVE SOME CONCEEEEEERRRRNNS
about mainly the laughing
Ohhhhh heey
Hi, OH hi.
hahaha
ohohohoho
uheheheheh
Hi, are you Scrappy or are you James Fazbear?
I like how one gets such a very noble title and the other one is SCRAPPY.
Oh hey Bonnie
How you doing over there?
So I was right this was one that was sort of like a Five Nights at Freddy's fan game
And oh my God, it is dark in here, and OH MY GOD.
OH MY GOD OH MY GOD What's in here? Hello.
Incorrect key card?!
What I have to escape?!
Did I suddenly
realize that this was a bad situation to be in it that I probably need to get the fudge out of here?
HAH?
Is that what I needed? Is that what I did? Is that what happened here? Okay good
Okay, you're still there. I've got my eye on you
I'munna- I'munna just adjust my
volumn here
And hopefully not die a horrible deathly death.
(Mark shudders)
(Alarm buzzes, Mark shrieks in panic)
AH FUCKING FUCK
What is that? OOOH that's not good.
Okay, all right then why do I need to do that? What is this about?
Why is there an outhouse in here?
(Thumping footsteps quickly approaching)
Ahh FUCKING-
(James Fazbear screams as he nibbles on Mark's gibblets)
(Mark doesn't like his gibblets nibbled)
Right.
Okay, all right, then we're gonna go with that one. We're gonna go with that's okay
We're gonna go with all that is normal there and everything is hunky-dory in La-La land inside this MUSEUM.
Great
Let's go back in again and see what else is in this horrible horribleness that we call this gameaaaah.
Hello, okay, then. I'm gonna activate this sunbitch and you better not come after me
NNNNHHHGGG
Alrighty then, well that's bad.
What is that?
Find the key card- this obviously isn't it.
Euuuuughhh
Okay, so how do I know where he is?
I'm gonna call him Scrappy anyways. I'm not gonna call him James. They're both gonna be Scrappy.
(Markipler is spooped)
Ooh
Ohh
(Whumpy whumperson)
WHAHEYEYHEYHEY HEY HEY HEY OHMYGODOHMYGOD OH MY GOD.
(The gibblet nibbles return )
Well, this is difficult isn't it this is just a little bit perturbencer. (?)
Fuck.
What'd- wait. what was that at the bottom? It said future island. What does that even mean?
(confused) Wait- what is that? I'm gonna go. I'm gonna go for it. I'm goin' for it.
(Mark mating call)
I'm gonna go for it. Okay, ah, I'm safe in here. You can't beat me. I'm too smart for you!
It's my brain power that's gonna get me through this, you know this to be true. You can't fight me on this one.
BEUUUuuuuUUUitch
"You've collected a new key". Okay. Do I get to test it out?
Yuuh, skedaddle skedaddle
Okay
(Quietly)Skedaddlin'.
Alrighty then
Hello?
It is so quiet in here. Oooo it is so quiet.
Let's try this one
hebitty hebbity
(cute boop)
AAAHAA GREAT
So none of them are gonna be right now. I'm gonna be wandering here forever and ever okay all right game
(Under breath) Sack of shit.
Now I don't know if the game is bugged out and he's spose- THE GAME IS NOT BUGGED OUT
(Quiet) okay
Haaalrighty then.
hello?
UUGH
EUUGHHH HI
Alright fine then. That's how you wanna play this?? Fuck. No, no I don't wanna play. Fuck, what do I do?
AHH WHOA HEY
(whispers in despair) fuuuuck
What the fuck do I do? He's just hiding there in the darkness. It's gonna be every other opportunity that he comes after me
I'm not gonna be able to survive this with my sanity intact
Fucking hell, I'm gonna give this one more go and now I'm gonna try Future Island cuz I'm pretty sure I'm gonna die here
So you know...
I feel like I'm a secret agent a very scared poop pants
poop pants filled Secret agent
All right, you guys think I should just round the corner and it sprint at him? Maybe I could give him a scare
That Scrappy son of a bitch
I collected a new key
(quiet) is it the one?
Doodly-Doo, Doodly-Doo
Sprinting down the Hallway Doodly-doo
Going to the door, doodly-doo. I got a key card, it's the wrong one.
(OH BOY!!!!!!!!!)
Ahh, Fuck me then
Here we go back into the trap of the
Animatronic and we're gonna die. A whole lot of death. A lot of death poisoning in this world. Oh boy
Here I fucking come Scrappy
oh fuck
ooOH GOD NO
Doodly-doo, trapped in a hallway, dead ends everywhere, fucking go
Fuck me then. Oh god why. Why did they build this like a fucking maze?
Runnin' away. Doodly-Doo. Don't know what to say, oh doodly-doo. I am gonna die, oh boy
Doodly-doo? Doodly-doo, here I go. Doodly-doo. Lookin' for the exit, oh DOODLY-DOO
DAH DOODLY-DOO! Doodly-doo, doodly-doo, going to the room and being real safe.
Doodly- doo, doodly-doo, goin' down the hallway, everybody sing now.
Haven't been down here, doodly-doo, doodly-doo
DOODLY-DOO
Doodly-I collected a new key. Gotta go. I uh oohhayee no
Oh god no. No please, please I'm too young. I'm too pretty! Don't kill me!
Look at this handsomeness
It can't be contained in a suit!
Nooo
NOOO
Scrappy! Alright you better wander off into the darkness.
I don't like the fact you can only hear his footsteps if he's like two steps away from you.
BWEEEH
doodly-doo...
AHH! DOODLY-DOOOOOO
Alright, well that's uh fucking impossible
Ok let's see, what Future Island is.
Oh. "Hi, there. I've decided to cancel Benetox as I realized that this would be a bit too big for my next project."
"But since I would like another project to work on I decided to come up with something new. So I named it Future Island." Ooohhhh
So there's the story. "Similar to Androids and Alien Isolation..."
Kickstarter, Ex Machina, six hour long campaign...
Sounds pretty good
So anyway that is Night Horrors.
If any of you guys wanna try to beat this I'll put a link to the game in the description below, but holy shit
That was awesome. That was terrifying but awesome, but they did a really good job here, and I kind of like it
I don't know if it's, like, it'll be fun in the long run, but what they got here was pretty terrifying to me
So thank you everybody so much for watching let me know what you think down in the comments below
And as always, I will see you in the next video
BUH BYE